well looks like including how we work
how we socialize and get life-saving
information isolation can also take a
toll on relationships and make it
difficult for singles to date biological
anthropologists Helen Fisher says now is
a time when relationships are either
made or they are broken she is also the
chief science advisor for match that's
the online dating site good morning to
you Helen good to see you good morning
so I don't see you too
well I want to talk about both kind of
relationships let's start with singles
first and then we'll move into people
who already have a partner because I'm
thinking if you're single
now would be the most difficult time to
meet somebody online or otherwise of
course I'm just asking for a friend
is this a crisis right now for singles
actually I think it's quite the reverse
actually it's an extremely good time why
because you know well because when you
five reasons basically you know when you
interact with somebody online sex is off
the table I mean there's not gonna be
any discussion about whether you're
supposed to hold hands or you're
supposed to kiss what you're supposed to
bring somebody home that's number one
money is off the table you haven't you
don't have to decide who's going to pay
the bill if you're gonna split the bill
you've got enough time even if you work
at home you've got time to do it now and
you've got something to talk about and
you've got a very intimate conversations
really you know your fears your hopes
your dreams or disappointments you're
gonna get to know somebody very rapidly
and I think most important it's a time
where none of us have ever done this
before we are all in the same jam and
when it's so novel and novelty drives up
the dopamine system in the brain and
dopamine is linked with feelings of
romantic love so we're almost primed
we're almost primed now to to start the
dating process and to get to know
somebody fast
well Helen then I mean the the second
set of questions then is about people
who are existing couples I mean like the
rhythm of a couple's life is usually
routed around work you're leaving the
house I'm coming home home this is a
pattern of things now you're essentially
locked in an elevator together for you
know an indefinite amount of time
getting to know one another again
tensions rise what do you do even when
you love each other
you love each other
but in my household wouldn't tell you I
think that they're I think there's some
three really important things to do
first of all you've got to create a safe
space even if you're in a tiny little
apartment and you're working
back-to-back you have to create a safe
space so that when you're in that space
they can't interrupt they can't talk to
you if they want to talk to you they've
got an email or text as if you're out of
the house as if you're out of the house
and in the office number one number two
you've got to create some routines you
know the human being needs structure and
so this is an entirely new situation so
at 10:00 a.m. you're gonna meet for an
exercise class in the afternoon you're
gonna have a quiet time you're gonna do
some storytelling before dinner you're
gonna dress for dinner you can't always
be wearing your your pajamas all day you
got a dress for dinner and I think it's
the time to make plans I think you
should start to plan what you're gonna
do on your next vacation what you're
gonna do when you have people over what
you're going to cook what you're gonna
wear how you're going to have a party
you need to create a whole pile of
things to do together and in fact I
think it's time to play the glad game in
fact you know I once heard about some
people who they got in a little sheet
and they put the sheet on the dining
room table and every single night they
would write down something that they're
glad about something that happened today
some tiny little moment when your
partner said something interesting so
it's a time to be creative that's good
go back to singles for a second about
the digital connection and I'm not even
talking about sex when I asked this
question but isn't physical touch and
physical interaction important there's
only so much I think a connection you
can have looking at somebody on a screen
that's why I'm thinking that it's hard
well it's a difficult time there's no
question about it but in many I mean we
are a mammal I mean we're built to touch
in the very moment we can get out and
touch somebody and look at somebody
across the table we are going to do it I
mean you know touches eternal and we
will get back at doing it I actually you
know really think that it might be a new
stage in the courtship process you know
first you're introduced to somebody and
that's all these dating sites are is
introducing sites then you get to know
them on the internet you see them on the
internet you
you can have a date on the Internet you
can decide to have cocktail hour with
somebody and have a drink with them on
the internet or even cook dinner with
them or watch a movie with them you know
there's all kinds of people who've had a
long-distance partnership for a long
time somebody who goes lives with a
truck driver or somebody who lives with
some buddies in the military they find
all kinds of ways to do things together
online this is entirely possible there's
a lot today to be worried about but this
is not one of them dating will go on and
I think in a very good way we'll get to
know people better faster all right I
hope you're right now Fisher dating will
go on mating in captivity will go on as
well I think the baby boom may be real I
know oh and they were talking at the end
of this where you they're gonna see hi
divorces or we're gonna see lots of
babies they'll be interested in a lot of
data on that
after Hurricane Hugo in 1989 there were
a lot more divorces but there were also
a lot more marriages yeah look at both
Thank You Helen we appreciate